the next one you want to racially
profile Muslims right was a painful yeah
now ironically yeah I've I've read your
piece on it if that's the case you
actually want to you're either Muslim
where you want to racially go yourself
I'm of the race that should be profiled
yeah so can you explain that a little
bit well so we've all had this circus
experience of going through security and
seeing people who at a glance you can
rule out as non jihadists I mean we all
I've argued for in the few things I've
said by profiling is that we should be
honest about what we're looking for
we're looking for Gia suicidal jihadists
now they're other you know their other
suicidal people who may bring down
planes but as a as a general matter
we're looking for people who are the
functional equivalent of the 19
hijackers right so we're not looking for
80 year old women from Okinawa we're not
looking for you know little girls from
Norway if Jerry Seinfeld was going to
the airport if he gets the same surge
that that's someone who looks like Osama
bin Laden does right that's a crazy
misuse of resources now there are little
wrinkles here that we we can correct for
it's possible to put a bomb in someone
else's bag so all bags should be surged
you can think this through but there are
people who you absolutely know at a
glance are not terrorists right and any
moment spent scrutinizing them in this
security theater we've all witnessed at
TSA is a moment not actually
intelligently looking for a more
plausible threat so I mean my my view is
we have $10 worth of attention if you
spend a dollar over here you've got nine
to spend elsewhere right so it's just a
zero-sum game and so my sense is because
I mean again we need well-trained smart
people at TSA to do that so it's not
it's not like we're well poised to do
this but when you look at what the
Israelis do when you look at if you ever
get on LL and you look at how they run
security yes they look at everybody but
there's
there's absolutely no pretense of being
fair in this process and there shouldn't
be right it's just like and when I go
through security I you know fifty
percent of the people to me look like
and I'm not I'm not saying that I'm an
expert here but I'm you know this I pay
attention to this sort of stuff a lot I
would be willing to bet my life that
certain people are just you know in this
blog post I've showed a picture of one
I'm a one you know old woman who you
just know right
it's there's just absolutely no way
she's joined okay so you look at her you
say okay the the the scrutiny on her is
a waste of time
and it's a dangerous waste of time and
in the interests of appearing fair we
are actually ramping up our risk and
what I were being appearing right
because yes appearing it's not actually
yeah but you and I fit the profile I
mean were you know young ish to
middle-aged men who could be we could be
jihadis right they're jihadis who like
as I said you know Adam Gadahn or any
these other Western recruits to al Qaeda
or Isis who functionally look like us
they're not they don't look like Arabs
they're not you know they're not holding
Pakistani passports so yeah no I'm not
letting myself off the hook here it's
not like I will you know I want me and
the other white guys to just sail
through it's just it's just they're
still people who are obviously not
jihadist and until these people start
blowing themselves up on planes I am I
think we're we'd be wise to just admit
we know what we're looking for right we
have some sense of what we're looking
for
yeah and just to be crystal clear in
that post you literally said I'm just
reiterating his what he just said but
that you should be picked out oh yeah
then you actually should be picked up
and I described it as anti profiling
it's not that I want certain people
profiled I just want us to admit that
certain people require less scrutiny and
you know Jerry Seinfeld is one you know
when you see a famous celebrity you know
they could go through security treated
as though he just may have become a
jihadist you know and you know it when
no one was watching it just it's it's
crazy making it is security theater yeah
and they're with their there are many
people who though not famous are
every bit as unlikely to be members of
al Qaeda as you know prominent people
who we know you know Betty White Betty v
Betty White is is I would not be happy
about that
that would be surprised yeah I still
have one if they wait
you